how's it going man it's good
um I mean that's a terrible way to open
a panel right it's good whatabout to
tell cancer let me ease you into this
great I can dig myself out of the cancer
hole watch this um it's my job as the
host to join you yeah I'm at the end as
we're talking right now I'm at the end
of a 11-hour trek to find pinatas it's
my daughter's birthday and I've spent
since 7:00 a.m. today driving around La
you'd think oh yeah I just go get a
pinata that'll take ten minutes she okay
first off every time when I'm when I'm
knocking it for pinatas doesn't it seem
like they're just pinatas hanging out of
every other store like we just got
pinatas in here and there's a spider-man
and a Shrek just kind of sitting there
FN Labs in New York yes yes so but what
but what sucks is my daughter is
obsessed with the movie frozen and
apparently the Disney people have taken
a snooze on getting the frozen pinatas
out there that they're just not out
there and my and my daughter is very
specific about I want I want to Elsa it
has to look like Elsa the main character
yeah all right so I'm a little torn a I
have to find it I have to find and Elsa
it felt like it was like the lamest
version of Raiders of the Lost Ark where
they really simple we're gonna update
it'll be set in contemporary times yes
and Indiana Jones is gonna be very
heavyset and sluggish and he'll be in an
SUV listening to podcasts and cursing
and looking for an Elsa pinata that is
his quest and not a bag of sand that
weighs exactly the same yeah have you go
in
dump a little bit up well this is the
last year she turning five and my
friends who have older kids say in a
couple of years
birthday parties turn into all boys are
all growth they don't want to mix
anymore really yeah boys want to do boy
stuff for their party and girls want to
do makeup and stuff like that I liked
hanging when I was little always with
girls yeah yeah less uh I'm sure my
father was like what